Fox News contributor former Speaker of
the House new kingrich you are very
confident after Iowa that you feel the
primary is over um I would assume that
position is not changed uh what do you
make of the rise and polls post Iowa and
do you agree with me that I think Ronda
Santa supporters are more likely to go
to president Trump than to say Nikki
H well first of all I agree with
everything you said about Governor Dan
sanas who I do think has a great future
has been an extraordinarily good
governor and I hope that he will stay
active in public life uh I think that I
just did a newsletter for tomorrow at
Gage 360 pointing out this is about to
be the longest general election in
American history I think it's something
like 287 days from Wednesday until
election day Donald Trump tomorrow night
will be the Republican nominee um if if
Ambassador Haley is wise she'll find a
graceful way as uh Governor danis did to
get out of the race if she's unwise uh
she will go to South Carolina and she
will be decisively defeated in her home
state and that will just shrink her
right now you have to have great respect
for her courage her determination her
energy her
articulation um she's about as high as
she's ever going to get uh and I think
if tomorrow night ends as Matt to
suggests and I think he's right uh it's
going to be Trump somewhere between 15
and 30 points ahead of her well two
primaries in a row against the man who
totally dominates the party nationally
uh the objective reality is it's over
and I think if that's what happens
tomorrow night uh that I hope Governor
Haley will decide that um she's done her
best just as Governor Dan sanis did but
that in fact this is now Donald Trump's
party and we need to unify to defeat Joe
Biden I I think what we're seeing emerge
though is a bench because let's say
Donald Trump's the nominee let's say he
wins the general election uh in four
years there will be a real Open primary
and uh I would not be at all surprised
to see people like Governor D santis
people like Nikki haly wanting to jump
in then as well uh at that point they
got to calculate you know this four-year
interim period of time now we now see
the biggest number that Donald Trump is
leading over Joe Biden we also see Joe
Biden has the lowest poll numbers he's
ever had 33% you see that he's losing a
big part of his base African-Americans
Hispanic Americans uh women young people
a big part of what we usually look at as
the base of the democratic party um if
that continues how could he possibly
come back
look I mean the objective reality is
that at a performance level this is a
disastrous Administration Biden's IL
illegal immigrants alone would syn a
normal candidate and they it's just
going to get worse it's not going to get
better uh Chicago announced yesterday
they have no extra space New York got so
desperate they kicked out American
school children for the night and
brought in illegal immigrants because it
was so cold uh I mean every time people
will turn around the illegal immigration
policy of Biden which is a deliberate
policy to open the border and have the
maximum number of people enter the US
illegally that's blowing up on the
Democrats everywhere second um the
country is not at all convinced by the
woke left-wing radicalism simple example
6% of Americans are willing to buy an
electric vehicle the Biden
Administration wants to make that 100%
well you can't in a free Society coers
94% of the country into doing something
they don't want to do so I think on both
policy grounds and performance grounds
Biden will get worse and worse weaker
and weaker Democrats will become more
and more terrified and I think this will
be a bigger blowout than Reagan over
Carter I think that this is one of the
amazing moments in American history and
Trump will have over 280 days to
crisscross the country strengthen the
Republican party and campaign among
groups who normally never see a
republican mean will have the time now
to design a true general election
strategy of trying to unify the whole
country and if you watch his tone he has
very correctly begun to move towards a
unifying bring us together solve
problems for example fix the big cities
not something Republicans normally talk
about so I'm encouraged that this could
be a remarkable general election but he
does have potentially as many as four
trials facing him what impact do you see
that potentially
having just pisses people off I mean I
had a woman today literally we were CH
and I were a giant doing some grocery
shopping and a woman came up to me
African-American works at the store she
said you know I'm not quite sure I'm for
Trump but I hate what they're doing to
him and I think it's really unfair and
it really bothers me and I think that's
true of almost every American if they
had picked one fight and gone after him
legally on one ground that might have
made sense but when you see them coming
at him from every single angle and of
course now with the with the uh problems
that Fanny Willis has in U in Atlanta uh
it begins to be almost like theater of
the Absurd you talking about County
County yeah bton County DA
well they got problems there they have a
lot of delays seemingly in the DC case
as well I don't think Alvin BR has even
decided what he's actually charging
Trump with the New York which was the
first set of charges so I mean God only
knows how that's going to work out
people and
yeah I just to say when people realize
that the District of Columbia voted 95%
for Biden that the current judge is a
radical left-winger that the current
prosecutor is so uh out of the rules
that the Supreme Court actually
admonished him for having broken the
rules and trying to get another
Republican politician years ago they're
just going to say this whole thing is
rigged and I I don't care what they try
to do to Trump when it's rigged the
country is going to Rally to the
individual Against The Establishment and
all they're doing I think they got Trump
the nomination uh at least a month
earlier I really thought he would get it
by uh the time we got to Super Tuesday I
never dreamed he would get it by uh the
end of the New Hampshire primary which
was really the last great stand of the
non-trump Republicans and it tells you
that what's happened is the radical
corrupt Biden J judicial department or
justice department has in fact so
alienated people that given a choice
whatever Trump's weaknesses May
sometimes be he is the person standing
and representing all of us who need
protection from an outof control
left-wing government and I think that
gives him a strength that we have
probably not seen in modern times wow
coming from you a great historian that's
an amazing comment new gingr great to
have you as always thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else